no serbian wanted to spend the day they
celebrate christmas on outside a budget
hotel in melbourne
their gift though was unwavering support
for their national hero
his first words from inside novak
djokovic said
thank you to people around the world for
your continuous support
i can feel it and it's greatly
appreciated
the border force in australia cancelled
his visa on arrival after the world
number one couldn't provide sufficient
evidence as to why he isn't vaccinated
against covet 19.
the australian government say it is his
decision to stay here and wait for a day
in court on monday
mr jacoby is not being killed held
captive in australia he is free to leave
at any time that he chooses to do so and
border force will actually facilitate
that
this now isn't just about djokovic a
handful of other unvaccinated arrivals
at the australian open have been given
medical exemptions
czech doubles player renata varakova who
had been let in has now had her visa
cancelled and she too is in the park
hotel with djokovic waiting to see what
happens next
in serbia they are still angry
and squarely behind their champion
i think he said that he is okay but
i'm not so sure but he's mentally very
stable
we we send him so many pictures
and videos so he knows that he have big
big support and doing that all our
nation is standing behind him
her son is one of the most determined
players on the tour it seems his mind is
set to stay and fight for his place in a
tournament he's won more times than any
other player
tom parmenter sky news